Why Jesus came late for Lazarus for 4
days? Was there any purpose for that?
Well, we already told within the
narrative if you go to John 11 and 14.
In fact, if you go to John 11, the first
four
verses, he already had been informed
that the one you love is sick. John
11:es 1 to4. But it says that Jesus said
that this will not be in vain.
This will result in God being
glorified in union with the son of God
whose glory would be revealed through
the death of Lazarus. So Jesus already
been told your friend is sick. So he
could have made it but he deliberately
stayed
behind waiting for Lazarus to
die and then arriving on the fourth day.
Now with that said let's pick it up.
Open up John 11 the entire chapter so it
will be easier for you. Read verses 11
to 15. 11-15. Okay.
After this, he said he had after he had
said this, he went on to tell them, "Our
friend Lazarus has fallen asleep."
Before you move on, brother, did you
catch it? No one had informed him,
meaning no one sent word to him that
Lazarus had died. Right?
Because if in John 11:es 1-4 it says the
sisters sent word to him. They sent a
message to him saying look the one you
love is sick. Get here fast. But now
notice that when Lazarus died, he
already immediately
knew. You catching that? Yeah. This is
one. He immediately knew, right? Yeah.
Shows his why. Oh, because he's God. In
other words, he's the God man. He's God
in the flesh. as God. He's omniresent.
He oversees all creation because it's
present before him as he sustains
creation with the father and the spirit.
And he already knew he died because who
controls life and death? Father, son,
holy spirit. The father with the son and
with the holy spirit control life and
death. Our lives, our souls are in the
hands of the triune God. So Lazarus
would not have died unless the Lord
Jesus in union with the father and the
spirit permitted him to die and
commanded his spirit to leave his body.
So he informs them asleep. But now they
still don't get it. They're thinking,
"Okay, he's sleeping. So then why
bother? He's going to wake up. So finish
it." Okay. He said to them, "Our friend
Lazarus has fallen asleep, but I am
going there to wake him up." His
disciple replied, "Lord, if he sleeps,
he will get better." Jesus had been
speaking of his death, but his disciples
thought he meant natural sleep. This
reminds me of the Muslims in Muafika,
but anyway, forget that. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Interesting. So then he told them
plainly, Lazarus is dead, and for your
sake I am glad I was not there so that
you may believe, but let us go to him.
So notice death is described as sleep.
Why? Why is that an excellent metaphor?
Because when you're asleep, you expect
to
awaken. Sleeping implies you will
awaken. Therefore, what our Lord is
teaching us is death is not permanent
and death does not result in the
secession of life where you cease to
consciously
exist. On the contrary, when you see
someone asleep, you expect them to
awaken. So when someone dies, expect
they will awaken, meaning they'll be
raised physically. That's number one.
Number two, even when someone's asleep,
they are still consciously alive. In
other words, their brain is still
functioning, their heart is still
beating, and they can still have dreams
and visions. When you sleep, you don't
seize to be. In other words, even in
that state of sleep, you can have
dreams, right? You see things and you're
conscious and your heart is beating and
your brain is still functioning.
Similarly, when someone is dead
physically, that doesn't mean they cease
to be conscious altogether because
they're still consciously existing in
another dimension in another state and
then they will return to their body and
awaken in that body. So, what a
beautiful metaphor for
death sleep. So, keep that in mind.
Jesus is
deliberately waiting for Lazarus to die
because he'll be
glorified through the resurrection of
Lazarus. A physical miraculous act that
will provide miraculous confirmation
that he is truly the unique divine son
of God, one with the father who does
everything that the father does in the
same way that the father does it. and to
confirm what he says later on
to Martha. I am the resurrection and the
life. So that's number one. Why does he
wait?
Because by raising a dead man to
life that becomes physical miraculous
confirmation that Jesus is unique divine
son of God who's one with the father and
the very resurrection and life. Now why
the fourth day? Because rigam mortise
sets in around the fourth
day right from my understanding and you
can correct me. I'm no medical doctor
but it's around the fourth day where you
have rigamortis sitting in the body
starts
decomposing. So most likely he waits on
the fourth day so that no one can say
well Lazarus didn't die right because
there have been instances in which
people were thought to be dead they
weren't right they weren't dead but they
were in a comeos state and they awakened
from that state but on the fourth day
rigam mortise sets in the body starts
decomposing and I've also been told but
I haven't been able to personally verify
personally
verify that there was a Jewish tradition
that the spirit of the departed would
remain in the vicinity of the body for 3
days and after 3 days the spirit would
would then depart. So by raising him on
the fourth day, this would silence any
objectors in claiming that well he
wasn't really dead cuz the spirit was
still attached to the body or he simply
was in a comeos state but he wasn't
actually dead and he simply revived.
This is why if you go to John 11 read
38-39 notice the reaction of Lazarus
sister. Read John 11 38-9 but then read
also 40 with it. Okay. 38. Okay. Let me
Oh. Uh, John 38-39.
Yeah, there's there's no chapter 38, but
chapter 11 38 39, brother. Then Jesus
once more deeply moved came to the tomb.
It was a cave with a stone laid across
the entrance. Take away the stone, he
said. But Lord, said Martha, the sister
of the dead man, by this time there is a
bad odor. Did you catch it?
It's the fourth day. By this time,
there's a bad odor. Why?
The the uh what does she say?
For he has been dead there four days.
You catch it. They realize by the fourth
day the body is rigamortis. It's now
decomposing. I see. Yes. So you see why
the Lord is deliberately waiting to
leave them with no excuse for rejecting
that it's a genuine resurrection of
someone who's genuinely dead.
Amen. You catch it? Yeah. All right. So
then what is the Lord's response in
verse 40? Did I not tell you that if you
believe you will see the glory of God?
There you go.